there's a lot going on in the news and
we are not going to talk about any of it
we're going to talk about a more
important question should conservatives
accept and embrace gay marriage do
conservatives need to embrace gay
marriage to survive we will speak to
YouTube star and the author of made for
love same-sex attractions and the
Catholic Church father Michael Schmitz
we will discuss what has become one of
the central preoccupations of our age
even though it only affects a relatively
small number of Americans we will
discuss a whole range of subjects with
regard to sexual morality and the
question of same-sex marriage and decide
once and for all what the GOP and
conservatives should do
I am Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Nolt Jew
[Music]
in 2001 Americans opposed monogamous
same-sex unions opposed including those
in the definition of marriage by a
margin of 57 percent to 35 percent by
2017 those numbers had more than flipped
to 62 percent supporting same-sex
marriage and 32 percent opposing it 56
percent of baby boomers support same-sex
marriage I think around 150 million
percent of Millennials support it even
41 percent of the greatest generation
the Silent Generation supports same-sex
marriage the leading demographic
supporting same-sex marriage are the
religiously unaffiliated the so-called
nuns who support same-sex marriage at a
rate of a shocking eighty-five percent
two thirds of mainline Protestants now
support same-sex marriage but those guys
will believe anything you know they're
wrong on a number of things mainline
Protestantism is basically just a
country club I think at this point
leading the opposition the same-sex
marriage or white evangelical
Protestants with only 35% of them
approving it though that number did rise
eight percentage points from 27 percent
in just one year
incredibly two-thirds of Catholics whose
pontiff calls gay marriage quote a
machination of the father of lies who
seeks to deceive and confuse the
children of God support same-sex
marriage 73 percent of Democrats and 70
percent of independents support it while
even 40 percent of Republicans support
same-sex marriage nearly doubling over
the past decade in 2001 one third of
both blacks and whites supported
same-sex marriage today two-thirds of
whites and half of black Americans
support it women are more likely than
men to support same-sex marriage though
both the numbers there they're high for
both 64 percent for women and 60 percent
for men sweet little ELISA is indicative
of this gender divide she has been
encouraging me to get a gay marriage for
years so that she can finally get away
and be free understandable how do we
explain this marriage shift on the
question of same-sex marriage to help us
answer that we are joined by father
Michael Schmitz and before we get to
Father Schmitz who has a wonderful new
book at and a lot to say I have got to
talk to you about a very important thing
that keeps our lights on this is zip
recruiter if you're hiring
me tell you something we have learned
this the hard way at the Daily wire the
way that we hire people is that we go to
the sidewalk in front of the insane
asylum and we pick out the craziest
looking person there is and we give him
either a job as a CEO or a producer or
an executive producer this isn't it
turns out the best way to hire people
what you should do is go to sip
recruiter every business needs great
people and a better way to find them
something better than posting your job
online and just praying for the right
people to see it that only works if
you're friends with father Schmidt but
if you're not if you're just
run-of-the-mill company you got a you
got to look for something else - as if
recruiter knew that there was a smarter
way so they built a platform that finds
the right job candidates for you a zip
recruiter learns what you're looking for
identifies people with the right
experience and it invites them to apply
for the job so a lot of job boards you
just post your job and it goes out into
the ether and nobody ever sees it and
that's it and they say they've given you
a service zip recruiter finds the people
for you it notifies them this is a
really important step these invitations
have revolutionized how you find your
next hire in fact 80% of employers who
post a job on zip recruiter get a
quality candidate through the site in
just one day and zip recruiter doesn't
stop there they even spotlight the
strongest applications you receive so
you never miss a great match the right
candidates are out there as if
recruiters how you find them businesses
of all sizes trust zip recruiter for
their hiring needs and right now I know
you always want free things don't you
people well that's fine my listeners can
try zip recruiter absolutely free that
is right absolutely free just go to zip
recruiter com /m KS that is zip
recruiter com /m KS what is it Marshall
slash MKS zip recruiter is the smartest
way to hire alright and they keep the
lights on that's the best thing about
those guys it's a great service but they
help keep come on man
support them ok we're joined by father
Michael Schmitz father Schmitz thank you
so much for being here thanks Michael I
right off the bat I have to apologize
that I do not have my hot or cold let
this here's mug I just have a DC Comics
I'm sorry that you know I I'm sorry for
you it's ok obviously
you know you can probably enjoy them in
just about any vessel they are always
delicious but this is the only one
that's fda-approved to maintain those
leftist years hot or cold always salty
and delicious so we'll have to get one
out to you right now in the it just to
protect your health protect the rectory
from the fallout absolutely right you
know you don't want you don't want them
go to go bad that's right oh they never
go bad they're all they stay great
forever and ever so for those of you who
don't know father Schmitz he has a great
YouTube channel I think it is fair to
say father Schmitz you are the most
prominent YouTube star among the
Catholic clergy you're at least up there
pretty big bishop merriment is big
father rut ler has some great videos
online
but father Schmitz channel ascension
presents has been viewed by over 11
million viewers he has a new book out
from Ignatius made for love same-sex
attraction and the Catholic Church
so father Schmitz to begin there are
examples we are always told in classical
antiquity of same-sex unions and even
unions that resemble marriage the Roman
Emperor Nero apparently sort of married
a young boy for us after the death of
his first two wives
he made his boy bride to dress up like a
lady at public events so Wikipedia tells
me now of course Nero did it is not
exactly an endorsement before they
married oh yeah right there's that daddy
exec yeah there there were a lot of
strange activities that were going on
and not exactly a guidepost for the
history of the Christian West marriage
has had a clear meaning the union of man
and woman this has been a consensus in
the West for millennia and now we think
it's the opposite now that that public
opinion has switched so quickly what has
caused it to flip within just a few
years well I think there's a number of
factors oh you don't even have to I
don't I don't think you even have to
appeal to any kind of like religious
idea I think you just when do we
disconnect from a real sense of I guess
rationality once we disconnect some
reason and once we actually I think it I
think in some ways embrace of
scientistic not scientific scientific is
great scientistic worldview where we can
just where the world is endlessly
manipulative or manipulative a bowl
we can basically redefine everything so
it's basically um comes from a thing
called legume I called nominalism where
if you name a thing that thing then it
just becomes that thing but there's no
such thing as a true nature of a thing
right so that now I just use the word
thing about sometimes in the last two
sentences but I always ask people okay
if you want to redefine marriage first
just define it and and blank blank blank
for bases blank stares back because it's
like well what a face when you really
love someone well okay that's a good
question or that's a good point I really
love my brother I love my sister this is
that marriage but no no it's when you
love someone and you and you're
committed to them like okay well what if
I love my my nephew and I'm really
committed to him and you want to see him
do well you my godson I want to see him
do well that the same thing you know as
know when you love someone you're
committed to each other and you really
help eachother flourish well right up
the road from here there's a convent of
nuns and they love each other they're
committed and they help each other
flourish in that marriage so like I
think before we even I mean it just it
basically anti a reason to try to
redefine something that you don't know
that definition I know that is such a
good point I noticed that they do this
and I think that it is a real strategy
of the left I think it's well thought
out because I actually see Donald Trump
using it very effectively on other
issues Donald Trump says we are going to
build the wall and Mexico is going to
pay for it and so we all start arguing
about who's gonna pay for the wall is it
gonna be Mexico is it gonna be the
taxpayers and he's gotten us to slide
right past his premise which is the
actually contentious question are we
going to build the wall it's the same
thing with marriage the left seems to
have blown right past the debate over
what marriage is and the definition of
it into who has the right to get married
so now we're arguing over civil rights
and of course if it's a question of
civil rights everybody is going to get
that right but that first question is
what is marriage and and the left is
insisting now that it is a monogamous
same-sex unions but for some reason not
polygamous same-sex unions those have
been excluded from the new definition of
marriage so the question on the question
of what is marriage why is it so
important that
be the union of man and woman yeah I
think that from the foundation of
civilization you recognize that the
essential building block of any
community I mean from from the smallest
tribe to the the largest nation the
building block the essential building
block is marriage and family what
because because we have a lot of
organizations right we have a lot of
people who are loosely committed to each
other but in no other relationship do
offspring happen and right and so that
that sense it like so there's no
propagation of the species for human
beings released outside of this
particular kind of relationship yeah you
can movies farm it out to the state you
could give it to the you know the whole
village to raise the child but the
village doesn't create the child and the
village doesn't provide a stable
environment for that child the only
reason why the state cares about
marriage in the first place
like why we have tax benefits why we
have some ports for those who are
married is because we say okay it's not
because we believe and love so much that
we just want to support you kids and
make it want you them you know make it
in this crazy world it's because you two
kids are gonna probably have more kids
when we want to make sure that those
children are taken care of and so why is
it so important because we're messing
with the we're really messing in it in a
way that we've never experienced before
I think as a species with this undef
initial I won't even say to redefinition
marriage it's an undef initial of the
most essential building block of a
society and so then you think about this
what happens if you try to build with
materials that have never been tested
before they you wouldn't you wouldn't
build any any structure that that was
solid you won't belittle any structure
that you could rely on because you don't
even know if the materialists are gonna
work and I think this is a really really
dangerous experiment that we're in the
middle of here and in our culture and
they say so often I find this to be the
case on essential first principles sort
of political issues I think that I
understand
the left's point of view but I don't
think that they understand our point of
view and very frequently they say they
mock people on the right or the
religious right and they say
they say that we say you know it was
Adam and Eve not Adam and Steve and they
refer to Genesis as some children's
fable that it has no meaning meanwhile
Genesis is perhaps the most profound
text to ever composed by human hands now
what they say is that you know if
children are this central aspect the
ability the the potential to create
children which is not to say that a
couple who is infertile you know a woman
who has difficulty conceiving or
whatever doesn't mean to exclude them
from it but excluding even the
possibility the logical possibility we
now have for instance single parents who
are able to adopt and we now so in that
case the question of children seems to
be a little tangential we know that a
gay people people with same-sex
attraction can adopt as though they're
single so now if they are in a same-sex
Union certainly they could continue to
adopt they say well marriage has been so
undefined already
they say for instance that divorce has
skyrocketed in modern years although the
rate has actually come down recently
what how do you respond to people who
say marriage has already been undefined
who cares if we had a little bit more to
them right well I think that it's kind
of like a well I guess that that panic
is already sinking and so we might as
well just you know play our instruments
and go down with the ship
rifles on the side of it actually I mean
look did that why don't I just you know
jump overboard and into right into the
ocean I would say that I think there's
something worth salvaging and I would
not deny the fact that like heterosexual
marriage is falling apart or people you
know what kind of having no-fault
divorce that and you know when that was
proposed we probably as people who care
about our country people who care about
our culture we probably should have been
a little bit more wary and a little bit
more cautious and moving forward with
that and could because we now we see the
fallout we see how this really has
affected children being raised by in I
mean even though children can say I love
both my parents in them getting divorce
that's good that they love them still
but they're there but they've been
affected by this mmm so to say like we
should have
we should have been stronger why not now
say let's get stronger rather than let's
just keep being weak so I think yes
there's a sense of like let's define
this rather than undefined it and let's
actually help like marriages become
better not just say you can't have this
too you know
a gay couple lesbian couple I think it's
really important and I don't see it with
people who are in my generation I don't
think that they have me in for a penny
in for a pound attitude I noticed that
all of my friends everyone in our
generation our parents were divorced it
was it just happened to our parents
generation and I noticed now people are
much more careful about marriage and
they seem to be obviously the plural of
anecdote isn't data but we do know the
trends are declining the divorce rates
and just talking to friends of mine
regardless of their political views
they'll say yeah I really don't want to
get divorced I'm really trying not to
get divorced I think that wasn't a good
experience and I I don't want to do it
myself I'd like to ask you a bit about
the theology of the body and by the way
guys this is where things are gonna get
real saucy but before we get to the
theology of the body we have to talk
about a much more important thing than
than all of these essential moral
questions we have to talk about
toothbrushes we have to talk about equip
this is important just as we keep our
moral lives clean and our you know we
keep our our ethical systems clean so
too must we clean our teeth and and tech
whip is the new electric toothbrush that
packs just the right amount of
vibrations into a slimmer design at a
fraction of the cost of bulkier
traditional electric brushes now I I
will say this this is a little bit of an
admission I didn't go to the dentist for
probably five or seven years I because
I'm a man and so I don't think about
these things I don't care I don't make
doctor's appointments I also didn't go
see the doctor
for a long time then I got engaged and
sweet little ELISA just took over my
life and made all of these appointments
for me and said if we're getting married
you're getting checked out pal and so I
go to the dentist and he excreted me for
several minutes over not using an
electric toothbrush apparently this is a
new invention and they made it for a
reason it's much more effective than
using regular I don't know I usually
brush with a stick or something I pull a
branch off a tree outside of my window
an electric toothbrush isn't much better
because it just
you all of those vibrations and brushes
much faster than you possibly could with
your own hand
so the guiding pulses alert you when to
switch sides on quip I mix the brushing
the right amount of time effortless quip
also comes with a mount that suctions
right to your mirror and unsticks to use
as a cover for a hygienic travel
anywhere I have it just right on my
mirror right now so I can go in your gym
gag or your carry-on and you don't need
to be disgusting like me and just throw
it in whatever the back of your car or
whatever because the thing that cleans
your mouth should also be clean quips
subscription plan refreshes your brush
on a dentist's recommended schedule
delivering new brush heads every three
months for just $5 this is the other
thing I know it sounds like I'm just
talking to the guys but it's because
we're so lazy about these things
I if I were not told to do it I would
not replace my toothbrush more than once
every 15 to 18 years I just wouldn't do
it
I don't it would be all mangled and all
the little bristles are coming out of
their probables are growing on the other
side of it you need to replace your
toothbrush it's very important it will
it'll just make your teeth smile
especially look these days with new
media everybody can be a star and you
can go on YouTube so make sure you got
to have those pearly whites this is the
moneymaker baby don't cheap out on
yourself
so most toothbrushes don't get named one
of Time Magazine's best inventions of
the year but quick did find out for
yourself why it's backed by a network of
over 10,000 dental professionals
including dentists hygienists dental
students and people who have teeth like
me I also think it's a great product
it starts at just 25 dollars and if you
go to quit oh I'm sorry if you go to get
quip comm slash Knowles kayo wles just
like Jay Z's wife right now you will get
your first refill pack 3 with a quip
electric toothbrush and that is a great
thing that is your first refill pack is
free at get quip dot-com slash Knowles
kayo wles that is GE t qu IP comm slash
Noel's what's the URL Marshall get quip
comm slash Noel's okay now that we've
we've talked about our teeth it's time
to get into the theology of the body and
and the theology of the body tells us
something about our mouth - the theology
of the body tells us that just as our
mouths
have a purpose to eat food and our eyes
have a purpose so - to our sexual organs
have a purpose and in spite of the
bizarre things that each and every one
of us wants to do to some degree with
those organs we should use them in
accordance with that purpose but my
question father is should we use them
only in accordance with that purpose so
my mouth is for eating but I also use it
to smoke cigars as did popes Pius the
tenth and pius xi even even a saint did
this Pope Saint John the 23rd also
smoked
similarly the central unit of human life
is the union of husband and wife it's an
image of Christ in His Church the
bridegroom and the bride but can other
arrangements ever be permissible or is
tobacco different because the body is a
temple in the temple needs incense
rather than the imaginative uses of the
sexual organs that we talk about so
frequently in our culture today ray
great question and actually I think that
uh-huh
I love the incense idea in the temple of
the Holy Spirit that's good I haven't
heard that one yet this I thought was my
only contribution to theology I think
that's an alone alone bit I have some
students who have asked me to bless
their cigarettes so he could have Holy
Smoke and I'm like I don't know dude I
don't know maybe the people calling
claim you can use it I don't know what
could white smoke I guess you know um
you know it's funny because I did a
debate with a man he teaches theology
and we were debating same-sex marriage
in the course of the debate he said
something that was really profound he
just stopped me he said well I'm not
defined by my biology and I'm ever just
thinking well wow like I must have this
look on my face that the moderator of
the debate recognized that I don't have
a very good poker face I'm like wow this
is she said father Schmitz do you have
something to say and I said yeah I
realized we're not just right here in
the in this moment we weren't talking
just about marriage we weren't talking
about sexual morality we weren't even
talking about morality what we would
have all came down to was a world of you
and the worldview is either Gnosticism
or it's basically a in fleshed
materialism or in sold materialism and
what I mean by that is like for the
Gnostics we
or mana keys would say that the the
body's bad the body's not you you are
truly your soul whereas as Christians in
the Christian worldview we'd say no body
and fold together and so like it was
remarkable that this person was was
admitting that that could there a
theology teacher at a Catholic school
they're saying AHA basically I'm Gnostic
I'm not my I'm not my body I'm just my
spirit or something yeah my spirit my
soul my psyche whatever and that's a
really profound shift in this world
because I think if we're gonna have a
debate about any morality issues any
sexuality asexuality issues or any just
like issues that pertain to what we do
with our bodies it's all gonna come down
to will question are you your body or
not is your body just a shell it's just
a case is it just but the true you is
somewhat kind of ephemeral and
disconnected from your body so you
mentioned theology the body which is a
term that was it came out of john paul
ii on Tiffa c't his teaching and in it
in that he said the body and it alone is
capable of making visible the invisible
the spiritual in the divine because to
be think about this we've never we've
never learned anything outside of our
body
we've never we everything you and i have
learned has been through a lot he like
through our eyes we read something or
saw something through our ears we heard
something we felt something we've never
expressed love except in and through our
bodies we've never expressed disgust in
accepting them through our bodies so
this reality is we've never known anyone
without a body and yet there's this kind
of worldview that says but no no but but
what I do with my body doesn't really
matter because it doesn't touch my soul
and so that's that's really ultimately
when it comes down to is again
Gnosticism erm anarchism so our starting
point has to be okay are you your body
and soul together or not because if
you're not then we're gonna have to
figure another way to talk about these
things if you are then I think we can
address the question you have you
brought up which is a really good
question which I mean um two things have
a nature and is that nature fixed or is
that nature determined by how we want to
use it and so I would say is I always
like to have the ask the question we get
the idea of a
I think nature the what it is nests of a
thing by asking the question what is it
for right so so we know what a chair is
because we we know that what it's for
nests of a chair to sit on and we have
the what it isn't is of a table when we
ask that what it's for in it okay the
set things on right what anymore I mean
what in isness of the michael null show
is to spread cough fa to spread cough FA
galore to all of the world of course
yeah and now you know what it's
coordinate and now you know the nature
and so the question is can I take
something that but what its poorness and
use it to my own end and the answer of
course is yes right so I can take mature
I'm sitting on and I can set something
on it and I'm not violating the nature
of what it's foreigners of a chair and I
could on this solid table out of God I
could sit on it and I'm not violating to
what its bornus to set things on of the
table but there are some things we can
do that actually do violate the what
it's warned us for example I couldn't
take this chair I'm sitting on and like
put a tree trunk in like split wood on
it I'd pretty quickly violate the nature
of the chair and same thing is true when
it comes to our body if I promise we are
our body then there's what it's
supported poorness so let's look at the
sexual act if you had a scientist to ask
the question what it's for what is it
for you'd see at least two things and
the two primary things that are there at
every every sexual act
there's procreation it's what it's for
and bonding of the couple that's what
it's for and when you see this on a
biological level both of the things on
the biologic level we're not even
talking about religion at this point
we're saying that note there are they're
bonding hormones to get released when
people enter into the sexual embrace so
that's what it's for knit yeah for
bonding and also it's the only action we
know of that's oriented towards making
new life so what it's born is is
procreation so does that mean that every
single act has to be to have a child or
every single act has to be for bonding
well we recognize that I'm sure that you
know you might know couples like we do
like who have been in the situation
where they're trying to conceive and so
they might say okay so she's like I'm
ovulating right now let's go that might
not be specifically for bonding
it's not the most romantic way to start
an encounter certainly Hey clock's
ticking buddy let's go get in there you
got a um but not for money but they're
not violating bonding right and by doing
this because they're both entering into
this as as we imagine a husband and wife
or you'd have a couple that you know
they're not in not specifically
intending to have a child come out of
this but they're not working against
this they just simply are we want to
express our local one another but
they're not working again the openness
to life mm-hmm in those cases they'd be
using this for a certain purpose but not
using at contrary to its nature and
that's the that's the big question
because we record what we recognize if I
use the thing against this nature I
would work against the nature or the
what it's for another thing that's when
things begin to break down this is
though this is the very note Foucault oh
I'm sorry go ahead
no no yes I've used my own purpose but
if I I can't extend that out or to any
purpose mmm and not expect things the
nature to break down this is that's a
wonderful explanation and this this
aspect the unitive aspect I think is
what's so difficult in a culture that is
obsessed with the erotic so the the
Christian answer to same-sex attraction
as you explained in the book is celibacy
and chastity to which we're all called
but for people with same-sex attractions
that obviously results in celibacy of
course that answer is easier said than
done we're all called to be chaste but
as as a former manichaean who became a
great saint Saint Agustin said Lord make
me chaste but not yet but not yet
doesn't the call for people who were
exclusively attracted to members of the
same sex exclude them from erotic love
one of the one of the great consolations
of life so I'm told is that burden not
too immense in a sex obsessed culture
such as ours that place is so high a
value on the erotic that's a great
question because I love how you phrased
it because we frame it in a in a in a
sex obsessed culture and so it makes
things more difficult I think is the
fact that that we've reduced everything
like all the greatest so john paul ii
again theology about it he said he said
man cannot live without love without
love men remains of being in comprehend
to himself he's a mystery to himself if
he doesn't experience love now we hear
that we think that it's the Pope talking
about because what we've taken is a big
concept of love and we've reduced it to
romantic love mm-hmm and we take them
account up the romantic love and reduced
it to sex though what it sounds like the
Pope is saying is man cannot live
without sex without sexy remains of
being incomprehensible to himself his
life is senseless unless he had sex and
yet the great mind the great heart the
great lives of history have said yeah
era you know a romantic love very erotic
love he's a good and we would have the
Christians we would say exactly I think
it's a good but it's not even the
greatest love because I love I read like
Fiat fluid thought he was one of my one
of my guys he said I believe Tolkien
referred to him as his heretic friend
and he is I do love CS Lewis I I love
the man I I devour him regularly
seriously so in the fourloves he talks
about these four kinds of love eros
this is always storge which is your
affection era which is the romantic love
and then he says but there's philia and
philia is not just storge like buddy
ness but his true friendship any-any he
says he maintained to make a rate case
for it that julia is even more uh more
rare therefore more precious and even
more life-giving than era which is why
probably I'm gonna imagine that you're
as you're preparing to get married that
you'd be saying like I'm not just I'm
not just in love with her she's also my
best friend this is better this all the
time I'm marrying my best friend and I
always wonder my fiancee says this I
always try to temper this because I
agree with you I say you know friendship
is so rare these days and I'm I'm
blessed to have a number of friendships
that I think rise to this level of great
friendship of true friendship not just
you know seeing your buddies and
catching a baseball game or something
but real friendship standing alongside
one another and looking at the same
thing and so when but one of which does
include my fiancee whatever I say well
you know you know my best idol best
buddy what are you gonna go to the bar
together I don't know but
female friend that's right yes she is
certainly my best female friend and but
you hear this so much and I it seems to
me when people say I'm marrying my best
friend
they are aspiring to this this sort of
friendship dysfilia that has been lost
that that ancient cultures and even
really just the pre-modern recognized
and spoke so highly of and and that
really seems to be lacking because all
our culture wants to talk about our
saucy or things than that absolutely and
so and so in that culture right we're
where true friendship is like well I
guess it's a consolation it's
consolation prize like maybe you have a
true friend but what would you really
wanted a lover yes it is more difficult
but I would say that I mean there's a
number of ministries there's even a
group in the Catholic Church called
courage and courage is men and women who
experience into subtraction or saying
but but we know the call of Jesus we
know the call to be chaste it that it's
difficult but it's not impossible and I
know I mean dozens and dozens just
personally and hundreds of hundreds that
I have encountered who are living really
healthy holy rich lives because
experiencing same-sex attraction is not
a death sentence I think sometimes
people think that that's the case if
you're gonna be Catholic or if you're
gonna be Christian that is like yeah
well too bad to be you man this is gonna
have a terrible liar it's never yeah
it's gonna be something that gonna be
difficult but every one of us that's
something difficult that we have to deal
with we're gonna wrestle with our entire
lives that sometimes it opens up doors
for us and opportunities and sometimes
it just it makes life really difficult
but like the people that I've
encountered who have same-sex attraction
who also are saying but no I I'm called
to be chaste
so I know what that means are living
really really full lives with true
friendship and that's not something I
mean I think if if most people knew what
true friendship really was it really is
they would they would say oh wow that
that's a blessed life not a not a cursed
life mm-hmm that's it's interesting that
is one of the jokes sometimes you hear
among guys who like to go to the cigar
bar and have some whiskey's and some
cigars you say well without the erotic
component being gay wouldn't be so bad
you know there was something the erotic
component doesn't sound great but other
than that it's a pretty pretty good time
there is so much more that I'd like to
talk about I'd like to get a little bit
more into the political aspects of all
of this and and into the question of
sexual identity why the left is so
obsessed with making the sexes seem
exactly the same in this question of
transsexuality which effects like five
people on earth but which has become the
number one political topic we've talked
about but I can't do any of that right
now I can't do any of that because we
have got to talk about something very
manly this I think is a providential ad
read that we have speaking of speaking
of the male sex man crates
man crates not only do these guys let us
keep the lights on but they are really
good I think I have two of my man crates
products just on me right here because I
just got a new man crate and let me see
if I can dig it out they gave me this
they just gave me this great new lighter
this new butane lighter
I won't light it so I don't torch the
whole studio they just it came in my new
cigar man crate let me see if it's in my
pocket never leave home without it this
brand new cigar cutter and it all came
in a an ammo box so I ordered the new
cigar humidor
man crate and it came into this great
ammo box I said where's the humidor I
open it up the the ammo box is the
humidor they fitted it out with cedar
and hygrometers and cigar booklets that
you can write about I love them the
first one I got was the whiskey
appreciation set that came in a gigantic
crate with a crowbar and I got mine
gift-wrapped because I love Christmas
morning and it's like whenever you order
a man crate it's just another Christmas
morning so you they dug a duct-tape it
that's the gift wrapping you open that
up you pry this thing open took me a
little it took me a couple tries it's a
little hard if you go to the Help
section of their website it says try
harder I'm a good advice always man
crates calm is the only place to find
awesome gifts that guys love guaranteed
so listen Valentine's Day is coming up
giving your guy box of chocolates for
Valentine's Day it's pretty boring I
like boxes of chocolates I eat them
frequently but you know we can do that
any day
we surprised him with a heart-shaped box
of delicious beef jerky
the ultimate snapper DZ ACK speaking of
theology of the body in the erotic I
will say oysters on the half-shell are
great but delicious beef jerky is quite
a snack for DZ ACK this isn't some
cologne sampler or cheesy mug man crates
offers curated gift collections for
every type of guy from the sports
fanatic to the home chef to the
outdoorsman you can check out classics
like the NFL bar where crate the whiskey
appreciation crate I recommend it highly
or fresh takes on Valentine's gifts
including the salami bouquet if my honey
give me a salami bouquet I would bump up
the date of the wedding I would be so I
would cry tears of joy and all over the
salami and make it even saltier I go to
man crates calm and then wait for that
magic moment the man in your life will
fall head over heels when his gift
arrives and he gets to pry it open with
a crowbar there are thousands of
five-star reviews every gift comes with
complete satisfaction guarantee
go-to man crates calm slash Knolls KO
wles for 5% off they don't know if offer
this discount anywhere else except for
maybe some of our other shows that is 5%
off right now at man crates dot-com /
Knowles what is it Marshall Mann crates
calm / Knowles and please send me one I
really like it send me a salami box or
salami bouquet would be so great and we
have so much more to talk about with
father Schmitz but you can't do it
unless you go to daily wired.com right
now what do you get you get me get the
under plane make sure you get the Ben
Shapiro show you get the conversation
which is coming up folks and I'm gonna
be in it so you can ask questions
everybody can watch only members can ask
questions many are called but few are
chosen you get all of that no ads on the
website but most importantly most
importantly for your safety for the
safety of your family for the integrity
of your house your property do not let
the fallout from radioactive leftist
tears affect you you this is a real
important matter here folks that you get
the leftist tears tumblr where you can
store it the leftist tears hot or cold
they'll always be salty and delicious
you can use it's very versatile vessel
so make sure you go to daily wire comm
we will be right back with more from
Father Schmitz
okay on the real political nature of
this Lobby
I think this Lobby that tries to make
our culture talk about sex and sexual
issues all the time it's it seems to me
that the issue of same-sex marriage is
part and parcel of a feminist ideology
that ironically seeks to erase all
gender difference so the premise of
same-sex marriage seems to be that a men
and women are exactly the same that
there isn't sexual difference because
very basically if M plus W equals M plus
M equals W plus W then M equals W
they're the same thing rather than being
complementary why does the left want to
erase sexual difference great question
I you don't like you and said earlier I
can understand the I often find out that
I feel like I believe that I can
understand the perspective and the
ideology or the thought process of
people who say I want to advocate for
same-sex marriage wanna advocate
advocate for transgenderism I think I
get the argument but then when it comes
to this like why when he asked the
question but but why then I don't then
at this point I'm thinking like what's
the ulterior or ultimate and it kind of
it eluded me because it seems like the
ultimate conclusion is a very very
different culture than we have one that
doesn't not net does not necessarily
flourish but one that kind of just is
everything's up for grabs and so when it
comes to like a lot of the motivation of
people who would advocate for like
claims of marriage or would advocate for
like trend kind of advocating
transgender stuff is it seems like what
I am talking with some high schoolers
asking them about this the response was
like well I don't know I just I just
feel bad that they can't get married
mmm oh well that's it and so and so I
think that there might be some people
who are like kind of masterminds I have
no idea who that who they would be but I
think at the by the core the reason why
the tide has shifted so
quickly is because we've abandoned
thinking and we've given it all over to
the feeling to emotion and so the reason
quote-unquote reason why that the tide
has shifted so much is because we've
abandoned reason and we're just saying
well I just I feel bad it makes me feel
sad to think that someone would feel sad
and and of course you know you unite we
don't want to make people unnecessarily
bad or want to make put undo like
suffering in their lives but that's not
the same thing as saying well but is it
so like you know so here's a person who
would say I don't I'm in a man's body
but I've always felt like a woman well
first of all I have to ask the question
how do you know right meaning like how
do you know what a woman feels like I
don't like playing baseball football
like okay that that's a stereotype right
there I I'm not gonna series I'm not
gonna advocated stereotype if you're a
man who doesn't embrace a lot of
masculine things like you don't want
your man crate or whatever that's like
that well that's unfortunate that I
believe is actually an unforgivable sin
in the scripture I have to refresh it
yeah I like that sense of like come on
bet I feel like woman how do you know
what a woman feels like and therefore
all you know is what you feel like which
is I feel disconnected from my body now
I am I for my part I I have a motion I
have a compassion for that and I have
pity on that but so the answer I don't
think is to say Oh in that case you must
not be a man right I mean I don't know
I'm sure you've experienced or not
experienced but you've encountered this
condition called diid which is body
integrity identity disorder what the IID
is is a real thing where people will say
things like I this isn't my hand always
felt like this is really part of me and
so they would go in to say the surgeon
and say could you every date why it's
perfectly healthy but it's not my hand
you know the medical community has
universally said no don't do that
because why because that give their hand
and the problem is not the hand the
problem is there's a disconnect between
their perception and reality right when
it comes to transgenders and when it
comes to sex it seems like we just
forget common sense and so if you know
if someone would say this is my hand no
no no that really is you're just
mistaken let's help you it took
place where you can make that like bring
it together but someone says these
aren't my genitals like wait wait well
then have surgery let's get rid of those
well we have to get rid of those that's
a different kind of coordinate then and
and because I'm well this this issue of
transgender does seem to be one where
people are suffering that sounds like a
terrible condition and I certainly feel
for people who have it but they seem to
be looking for relief in all of the
wrong places the pioneers at Johns
Hopkins who began the gender mutilation
surgery have stopped doing it because
they realized that even the suicide
rates of people who suffer from this did
not decrease after surgery so even the
operation that everyone expected to give
relief to this condition didn't quite do
it and this does seem to be the real
issue because I always a fear for when
we're talking about this issue people
didn't choose to be born attracted to
members of the same sex I don't think I
don't think anyone ever said yes today
I'm going to do that and it that is a
really sad condition if one looks at a
traditional Christian view of things or
a Jewish view of things or any other
traditional sexual ethic and they say
I'm excluded from this and I I really
wish I weren't excluded from from erotic
love or from pursuing my sexual desires
and I think a lot of the time Christians
in the Catholic Church in particular are
called haters on this they just they
think that we just hate gay people and
we don't want them to be happy and when
really what we're saying is this isn't
an a normative statement it's a positive
statement that this is not what marriage
is how do you respond to the accusations
of of hatred and bigotry you know it
seems to me that it's it's similar to
saying I like apples but I won't call an
apple and orange this question of gay
marriage and they say well why do you
hate oranges and I don't hate I like
oranges very much I want oranges to
thrive I like orange juice
probably screwing up the metaphor
somewhere here but I don't paint oranges
I just think that apples are not oranges
how do you respond to those accusations
of hatred yeah I would say leave two
things one is I remember the person one
very very close to me when he came out
of it came out to me he he wanted me to
watch a video and so I watched this new
kind of documentary it was a made by a
man who had two relationship with
another man and it ends tragically where
the other man died true story
he said I want you to watch this because
the one guy said when I came out to my
parents introduced him to Shane with the
man named my nieces and nephews call him
uncle Shane and I hoped Emily loved him
and it was it was great but then when
Shane told his family about me they said
if you two ever show up on our front
door you'll be men at the door with a
shotgun and I remember him showing me
this this video and like I'm thinking
like what what what does he want like
you know so it's video ends and he says
what do you think and I said ah are
those my only two choices like because
that sense of like is it is it I'm gonna
have to embrace and agree and celebrate
everything you choose or I'll eat you
yeah yeah because like I don't like
either of those and and it was funny
because um I I probably am not closer to
another human being on this planet that
I am to him is I love him very very much
is that even said something interesting
his dad said no good parent agrees with
every decision their child make because
that's not a real relationship errants
do but no good parent doesn't that's not
a real relationship is it where I can't
disagree with you and you can't disagree
with me because I have to just always
celebrate every choice you make no I
don't maintain that anyone would choose
to you know feel transgender to choose
to experience a misdirection and so I'm
not saying that I'm saying choose to act
on something and I think that when it
comes to being you know accused of being
haters the church or Christians or
whoever I need to be really really clear
about like minimun oh we love this
person's actually so this this man back
in 2012 we had a gay marriage debate in
Minnesota and so the oles law lawn signs
all over the place and so there was you
know read
fine marriage and some keep students
marriage defined well and remember this
man had come over with his his partner
at the time to the house and and
everyone in the house just absolutely
loved the two of them because they're
great guys and we just of course I mean
well you know what we believe you know
when we know what you believe but we're
gonna love you and it was so interesting
because as they drove away this other
one the yard sign and one said to the
other said wait a sec I'm just so
confused why because bait they loved us
yeah but they have this sign like yeah
it was this cognitive disconnect of
course wait you can disagree with me and
still love me absolutely is the cake and
this and and I think the popular press
and the mainstream media and lefties the
secular left they don't understand that
when Pope Francis set calls gay marriage
the lobby for redefining marriage and
redefining gender and sexuality calls
that a machination of the devil but
simultaneously says who am I to judge I
have plenty of my own sins my own sins
of the flesh and even you know Dante put
sins of the flesh much higher up then
says of deception or whatever though in
terms of levels of Hell the adulterers
and sins of the flesh they're kind of
swirling around in the in the upper
echelon so you know it's really the the
betrayers who are way way down lower you
can get far worse and that second piece
of like you know when it when you say
why does why is this no how would this
not hate remember uh talking with
someone using the example of baseball
and football so you know baseball
there's there's a lot of flexibility
when it comes to baseball you can have
you know the the base is 90 feet apart
like normal you can have you know and
honestly you cannot have no one you can
you do it yourself you can have the
bases actually being those canvas things
stop with whatever or you can having a
first base as someone's mitt second base
is someone's t-shirt and you're third
base is you know a hat and there's some
flexibility but to play baseball you
need at least three essential elements
you need a baseball a baseball bat and
you need to try to hit the ball with the
bat to score a run and so go but those
are the essential things you maybe take
away the baseball and replace with a
softball you have different game
Ocampo there's a football or
yes you take away the the bat and now
you have catch you're playing catch you
take away uh they're trying to hit the
ball with the bat to run around the
bases to score a run and you're just
having batting practice or fielding
practice but play baseball you need
those three essential things so it's not
limitlessly undefined you know if they
had some some sense no cue comes a
football players says hey wanna play
baseball and great yeah you're up next
you know but but I I want to keep
playing football but I want you to call
it baseball you think we can't do that
we as you can because you know you guys
don't have an OP or you know we have
enough or you plan us on a field we play
on a field you have teams we have to you
it's the same game okay
but you don't have the essential element
in it I'm not even gonna get to the
plaintiff like complaining about
football I'm saying it's not as good as
baseball right I'm just saying they're
different things and unless we can
define a thing to say it's different in
some people's mind means you're saying
it's bad and they're like wait a second
but um I'm just let's just start with
saying these are different things that's
a great point to say I'm married and I'm
not gonna same-sex relationship I don't
even have to say one is that I can just
say they're different that's right
and leave it at that inherent in that
there is an make without making any
moral statement whatsoever it you're
making simply a categorical statement on
the nature of two things that is a great
point now much more important than any
of these things this has been a
excellent discussion pretty illuminating
even for me and I've just finished
reading your book which I enjoyed very
much much more important than any of
these things
father Democrats have become very
extreme on abortion they now insist on
killing pain capable late-term babies
next up will be fourth and fifth
trimester abortion they support
redefining marriage into nothing next up
will be polygamy and szilágyi me that's
the new thing where you marry yourself
more on that on another episode but it's
seen this pretty rough I think that's
from Sex in the City as are many
terrible things in our culture according
to Pew Research while all the votes were
relatively close Catholic voters in
America picked Al Gore over George Bush
Obama over McCain Obama over Romney in
2000 2008 and 2012 a large number of
Catholics also supported john care
and even Hillary Clinton why do
Catholics vote for Democrats I think it
goes back to this kind of sleight of
hand and the sleight of hand it has to
do with Catholic social teaching is a
real and really important thing and it's
a real thing real thing it's really
important thing Catholics will teach
social teaching and so when you were
raised Catholic you you hear like okay
care for the poor care for those who are
marginalized care for those who are weak
and those that the world that one wants
to forget about you're told this it's
true and then it comes along a political
party that says hey we care for the weak
we care for the marginalized we care for
the poor we care for those who are
bullies we care for all these kinds of
things and I think there's kind of a
bait-and-switch kind of thing happening
where Catholics say well yeah that's
what that's what I've been like I buy my
conscience has at least been formed in
that way and so well I know that they
support abortion all the way to the end
I mean even like you know partial birth
abortion that people would vote for this
craziness they're good it's gonna be no
mr. abortion that's gonna be the next
thing I gotta bury and then we had that
but but but what about all those people
as they're helping with helping refugees
they're helping this and this and this
and I think I just think it's a lack of
black and good formation and the lack of
act and I would even say not only
formation I would say lack of courage
that that's absolutely true because when
it comes down to it I think that as a
church a lot of Catholics have become
really really comfortable and we're
comfortable with status quo and so you
know I got a call the other day from a
youth group leader who is saying that
there's some young people in her in her
school ku they were in South Dakota in
Sturgis South Dakota there's a group of
transgender high school students in this
high school and I got interesting and
and she said our youth group kids you
know we're trying to be nice to them it
would just really mean back to them and
and I said what do you mean really mean
there's well the game's dirty looks when
they said hello in the hallway I thought
okay well looks on the break that's not
being really mean so ubiquitous sort of
thing that happens in high schools and
yeah
yeah I was like and so I think that you
know I understand what's going on but
but we need to actually prepare the
people perceive and prepare ourselves
it's really it's okay if people don't
like you Jesus actually even said people
are going to hate you for my sake I
think I say and then it's inside like be
able to say what I'm gonna do the girl a
pair I was gonna say I don't know if we
could say that on air on this show
anything goes that's that's some of the
most polite thing you can say on my show
I'm in a pair of eyeballs and really see
the truth mr. says I'm like I'm sorry
but please finish the point no but but
that I think winnings information and
courage and I think that one the stories
that we're really lacking as a Catholic
Church is formation and really giving us
encouragement to be courageous I love
that point so much I that I think that's
how I've got to sign off my show from
now on as father Michael Schmitz tells
us all grow a pair of eyes to see the
truth father Michael Schmitz author of
made for love same-sex attractions and
the Catholic Church and you can catch
him on YouTube
father Schmitz thank you so much for
being here I've really enjoyed it and
for everybody else this that's our show
that's our whole show today come back
tomorrow tomorrow by the way is our
100th episode you don't want to miss
that
we have some we have some fun things
planned we've got crazy new technology
that is going to shape our show tomorrow
but you'll have to tune in to see it
that is it I am Michael Knowles this is
the Michael Nolt show tune in tomorrow
we'll do it all again
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Marshall Benson executive producer
Jeremy bore senior producer Jonathan hey
supervising producer
Mathis clever our technical producer is
Austin Stephens edited by Alex zingaro
audio is mixed by Mike Cora Mina hair
and makeup is by Jeshua of era the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018